first of all before we get started I
would like to thank the sponsors and
organizers of pilot of Seattle to make
this amazing talk happen and so I in
front of belem data scientist at c2fo I
majorly involved there to build the risk
management system and this is Jonathan
stack he's a DevOps engineer at c2fo so
today we will be talking about how to
build robust automated forecasting
system in python and our before I dive
into the techniques that we can
implement on time series data just to
give you an overview for those who don't
know what time series data is so it's a
series of data points indexed in
chronological order with the equal time
space in between so let's suppose if
you're dealing with data a daily data
then we have observation for every day
so in this in time series we have time
or date as the independent variable and
the values as the dependent variable so
I have this fictitious data that I used
to represent how time series it actually
look like on the x-axis I have the time
on the y axis I have amount just showing
a fictitious data for the financial
transactions so the blue represents the
actual time series data whereas red
represents the forecasted value which we
can get once we build the forecasting
models so let's get started so the goal
of this talk is to demonstrate how we
can make millions of robust forecasts in
an automated fashion so first I will be
defining the problem and then I'll walk
you through some of the pre-processing
steps that we can implement for time
series data which involves profiling the
data applying different kind of
transformations on the time series data
and then detecting for outliers or
anomalies once we know how to
pre-process the data I will walk you
through some of the strategies that we
can apply on time series data and the
packages that we will be using are from
Python and R and then too
to calculate the forecast quality of the
forecasting models that we'll be
implementing I'll walk you through some
of the evaluation metrics that we can
use to calculate that and then once we
have our software architecture build up
I'll be walking you through how we can
choose the best hardware for a given use
case or in this case it will be the
problem statement that we are solving so
the forecasting that we do on daily
basis is used throughout our
underwriting process and because of the
problem statement that we are trying to
solve
we are biased towards the risk aversion
and on daily basis we do the prediction
for more than 250,000 unique time series
or we call them as accounts and and the
data grows at the pace of around 2x
every year so the initial goal we had
was to keep the runtime of complete
pipeline under five hours at the same
time optimizing for the cost and keeping
it under two hundred dollars per day and
the aim of doing all this is to reduce
the forecast error by ten percent
compared to the current pipeline so and
these are some of the simple formulas
that we use to estimate the run time and
cost for every pipeline run so these are
used to tweak some of the variables that
we have in our case right now we have
the number of servers as the main
variable so if we want to reduce the
runtime we can bump up the number of
servers we will be running our pipeline
on so to calculate the runtime in our
numerator we have number of unique
accounts for in number of unique time
series will be forecasting for
multiplied by the number of strategies
we will be running multiply that by the
number of transformations that we will
be applying on the time series data and
divide that by the number of servers
we'll be running our complete pipeline
on x the course each server has into the
mean forecasting time per unit time
series and once we have the run time
calculated we can easily
calculate the cost in which we just
multiply run time with the number of
servers we are running our pipeline on
multiplied by the cost per server so now
let's see what different steps can we
can perform to pre-process the time
series data
the very first step that we can do is to
profile the data in which we make sure
that the index of the time series data
is off time off type timestamp and then
we check for the completeness of panel
by which I mean let's suppose if you are
dealing with the financial data we don't
actually see transactions every day so
to fill on those days where we don't see
transactions we just fill the null
values and one of the most important
thing to take care of if you're dealing
with the daily data because the
frequency for daily data is 365 so just
remove the leaf days and if you're
dealing with the time series data which
has seasonality so make sure before
doing any kind of forecasting your data
has at least one complete season and
also make sure that you truncate any
incomplete season from your data so as
to demonstrate that as you can see in
this graph so first of all red reflects
the original time series that we had and
blue reflects the profile time series so
as you can see there's some data after
2017 if let's suppose we are dealing
with the daily data doesn't seem like
that it's a complete season so we try to
get rid of that extra data but rather
than getting rid of that data from the
recent history we just get rid of the
data from the past because recent
observations are more useful to make
future predictions and then other said
that we can perform under pre-processing
imputing the missing values so one of
the simplest way that we can do by
filling the missing values is using
descriptive statistics like mean or
median to replace the missing values the
other strategy or technique that we have
is called interpolation so
if you look at the very first graph we
have a disconnection in the time series
which reflects the missing data so idea
behind the interpolation is to take the
coordinates where we see there's a
disconnection in the time series and
apply different techniques like linear
polynomial and/or cubic and then replace
the missing data accordingly as we can
see in the second graph whereas
extrapolation is a technique which we
use when the missing data is at the very
end of the time series as opposed to
what we see in the interpolation and the
strategy we can use in extrapolation is
forecast a training model or forecasting
model on the time series data and then
make predictions for the missing values
in time series the other thing that we
can do is detect for outliers or
anomalies so just to give you a brief
how they are different so outlier is a
data point or a bunch of data point that
lies farther away from a statistical
mean or median of your data distribution
and some of the common ways to look for
outlier is plot box plot or you can
decompose the time series into different
components like trend seasonality and
residuals and work on the individual
component to look for outliers
whereas anomaly is an illegitimate data
point in the data distribution that you
have by that I mean let's suppose if
you're dealing with the weather data and
then you are looking for a weather data
for a city which experience hot summers
and you're looking at the summer data
itself and then you experience our you
see an observation which is pretty low
like 40 degree Fahrenheit which looks
like an anomaly so one of the common way
to detect the anomaly is to divide your
time series data into train data and
holdout set and then build a forecasting
model on the train data and calculate
the forecast error for the holdout set
and once you have the forecast error you
can compare that to the threshold
through which you can detect if it's a
data point in the time series anomaly or
not and that satchel is again dependent
on the use case or the type of data that
you're dealing with so yeah this is one
of the interesting example that I wanted
to bring up so this is a fictitious data
that I am using so one of the ways we
can detect or remove outliers is just if
you can see in the first graph the data
looks pretty stationary so the so the
technique we are using is like any data
point which is beyond a second standard
deviation we just get rid of that that
that looks like working fine for the in
the very first graph because we have a
stationary data but if you try to imply
the same thing for a data in which we
have moving mean and moving standard
deviation that doesn't seem like working
as we expected because seems like we are
getting rid of some of the legitimate
data points here so just keep in mind if
you are dealing with data with trends or
moving means so this is not the
technique to use for outlier detection
so now as we know how we can pre-process
the data let's look at some of the
forecasting models or strategies
different type of strategies that we can
implement on time series data so one of
the strategies which is pretty common is
using regression models so in regression
models we can build models like OLS
polynomial but the problem with the
regression model is like if you're using
just the univariate time series data
trend not always follows the parametric
behavior and even if it does you will
end up with the residuals with high
correlation but you can use the
regression if you extract features out
of time series and then you can build up
some of the complex regression model
like XE boost then we have other models
called ARMA known as auto regressive
moving averages
so ARMA and smoothing models share a lot
of common characteristics so first of
all they are based on the idea like
tomorrow's prediction is based on
today's data and some of the recent past
data and also they are mostly used when
you're dealing with just univariate time
series but the only difference or the
major difference is some of the
smoothing strategies can also be used
for nonlinear data whereas arma is
basically used for for the situation
where you're just dealing with a
univariate time series and then we have
structural models also known as
state-space models so the idea behind
these models or type of strategies is
tomorrow's prediction is basically
dependent on today state only and the
idea behind using these model is when
you are dealing or when the time series
data observation value is not just
dependent on the time but also some of
the other factors like in stock market
there is no price over the weekend so
now we know how to build different
forecasting models on the time series so
let's see how we can evaluate the
forecasting quality that we get out of
those strategies so there are two
different types of evaluation metrics
one is scale dependent which requires
that two time series models that you are
comparing or two time series that you're
actually comparing should be on the same
scale like you can use a time series
which are observation in kilograms and
other in grams so some of the common
examples for scale dependent or mean
absolute error where we take the mean or
forecast error and forecast error is
just the difference between the
forecasted value and the actual value
and some other examples are mean squared
error means forecast error and root mean
squared errors so whereas a scale
dependent which is other type of
evaluation metric this is used when you
have
time series two time series that you're
comparing on a different scale so we can
use scale independent just because so
most of the examples for scale
independent is our percentage errors so
here we care about how much by how much
percentage are we away from the actuals
so as you can see in mean percentage
error we are dividing the forecast by
the actual values and then multiplying
the mean of that to the hundred to get
the percentage so other example is being
absolute scale error so this is actually
based on the idea to to see your
forecasting model is how far from the
knife model in which today's prediction
is solely dependent on what is
yesterday's observation value was and
now we know how to perform different
steps and build forecasts let's see how
we utilize all that information for our
problem statement so our problem
statement is divided into two sub goals
one was run time optimization in which
we will try to narrow down different
strategies and transformations that we
can apply on the time series data and
then we other other goal that we have is
cost optimization in which we will try
to use different options for the
hardware's to reduce the cost for each
pipeline run so let's see how we
optimize for the run time so this is the
graph to show what was our initial
approach our initial approach was to
implement different strategies that we
can on our time series data and then
also apply a different transformation
for now for initially we just used log
transformation and default here reflects
a data without any transformation and to
measure the forecasting quality we went
ahead and used bunch of different
metrics because we had no idea and we
wanted to get a feel how or what kind of
results there
output and if they fall in consensus we
might just you use all of them and then
once we have that we implemented all of
that software part n Python version 2 as
well as Python version 3 so as I said we
wanted to build a robust forecasting
system so we wanted to see which Python
version is performing the best or our
use case and then once we have the
software part figured out we will see
which hardware instance order type is
best for our problem state so the very
first experiment that we performed or
before I get into the experiment so we
use thousand different unique time
series or thousand accounts so and those
thousands of accounts or unique time
series reflect the diversity of the data
that we deal with on daily basis so we
exceeded all the experiment on those
thousand accounts and yeah so the first
experiment was to get the feel of
metrics and see if all of the metrics
fall in consensus and so if so then use
all of it otherwise try to get rid of
some of the metrics which are throwing
away redundant information or if they
have any kind of conflicts so let's see
okay before you get overwhelmed with
this graph let me explain you what this
graph is used for so this graph is to
compare all the different strategies
that I mentioned in last slide so we are
running all the different sorts of
strategies with the different
transformations and we are comparing
their results across different metrics
which which are labeled on the x axis on
the y axis we I have the number of win
cons or number of accounts for which a
particular strategy and transformation
combination one so if you look at so
also there's a there is a continuous
line and a dotted line with the same
color so continuous line reflects a
strategy built on the default data which
is non
and form data and dotted reflects the
same strategy built on the log
transformed data so just to give you an
example if you look at the dotted line
the orange dotted line under MPE which
is the very first metric the count seems
to be around 125 so what it says is like
out of all thousand accounts we
experimented so that dotted orange
reflects P log or taurima so python
auditory Maran or with the law of
transformation so that is winning 125
times out of thousand unique time series
that we experimented so in this graph
I try to bunch all the different metrics
which have same characteristics together
so if you see on the left so left to the
ma se which is kind of in the middle is
the scale independent matrix and
everything towards the right of ma se is
scale dependent matrix so if you look
closely there's a huge conflict between
the percentage error matrix which are
first three compared to any other
metrics that we have and this calls out
for the situation where we should not be
using percentage errors which was our
problem statement so in our problem
statement and our axles or test data or
holdout set we had zeros and if you
remember in percentage error we divided
forecast error by the actual values so
if you divide something by zero is just
give you error but to to to just get rid
of that we added a small constant but
that still didn't seem to be solving the
problem so we thought of getting rid of
all the percentage errors because either
way we are dealing with all the time
series on the same scale and then the
other thing that we look for if you look
at MSC our MSE and SSE towards the right
side we can see they are showing some of
the redundant results so we thought of
keeping this one metric and getting rid
of other two so similarly
we went ahead and got rid of anything
which is marked in the red block so
ultimately we were left with mfer MFCs
map and maze so now we know what matrix
are useful for us so let's see what else
we can do for optimizing the time so the
next experiment that we ran was to get a
feel how our different strategies are
performing so let's see how they are
performing and and one more thing that
we wanted to look in this experiment was
to try different parameter values for
different strategies that we are
implementing but initially we started
off with the default parameters except
for pi flux one of the strategy that we
are using we used reduce number of
simulations for that so again this is
kind of the graph that we had in Las
experiment on the x axis I have metric
on the Y I have number of wind counts so
the purple one which is at the very top
reflects our auto remove with default
transformation which means no
transformation that is winning over or
that is winning followed by T bats
followed by Python Auto rima followed by
profit so those are those seems to be
performing really good for our unique
time series that we have but then if we
look at the very bottom so every color
or every line associated with five slugs
seem to be lying at the very bottom
which means by flux is not actually
performing good for our use case or our
problem statement so analyzing that we
thought of getting rid of pi flux from
our strategies and just because so the
most time consuming thing in this whole
architecture is strategies so we wanted
to see if we can do something more to
get or reduce the time so I forgot to
mention one thing earlier so PI ARIMA is
nothing but the
implementation of our Auto Rima and
Python so this is a homegrown algorithm
so we wrote it according to our problem
statement so so the so the idea is
because if you remember the last graph
our Auto Ramone was performing the best
out of all the strategies so the idea
here is to get rid of Python
implementation of ours Auto Rhema if the
difference between the forecast of
Python Auto Rhema and our Auto EEMA is
not too much so we looked at the cases
where only Python Auto Remo is winning
and we wanted to see at the and we
wanted to see how our Auto Rhema is far
away from Python Auto Rhema forecasts so
we went ahead and looked at the median
of differences so and we be calculated
differences amongst all the different
metrics but here I'm just showing MFE
and rmse and so the values that you can
see here for mm Fe for the default
transformation or no transformation was
1367
similarly for log transformation was
1337 31 for our use case it was under
our expected limit so we went ahead and
got rid of Python Auto Rhema now we have
our strategies figured out so we went on
to transformations and added like
research a bit and added one more
transformation which was box-cox
transformation and then the another
experiment that we performed was to
figure out which Python version is
performing the best for our use case and
to do that what we did was like we ran
combination of all strategies
transformation and different hardware we
want to experiment and there were total
of 45 combinations we came up with we
wanted to compare the timing of Python
version 2 to the python version 3 I know
it's a bit confusing this graph the only
thing that we have to care about is the
read reflects the Python words into
processing time where
blue reflects the Python words in three
processing time and most of the cases if
you just over look we can see red is the
the value for red is higher which
reflects Python version two is taking
more time compared to Python version
three and to summarize this graph I
compared the timings against different
calculation types one was pre-processing
how it is performing all different
versions are performing for
pre-processing and then modeling which
was the main part and then at the last
comparing the cumulative times so as we
can see Python version 3 seems to be a
clear winner here so we went ahead and
got rid of Python 2 and declared Python
3 as our version for new pipeline and
now let's see how we can decide what
hardware works the best for us we
already ran all the different
combinations and we already had the
timing for all of them so we just
compared the timing across different
different Hardware types that we want to
one our pipeline to be running on or
different hardware's that were available
and we compared the time as we can see
so the very first here is see for a type
so which is a compute optimized hardware
instance so and that makes sense because
we are doing a lot of modeling which is
compute heavy so c48 seems to be a clear
winner here so we went ahead and got rid
of other hardware types and we decided
to run our pipeline on the compute
optimize system and then we had
everything figured out except that we
just wanted to optimize some of our
runtime more if we can then we had two
questions one was is there any strategy
which is taking longer time compared to
other strategies and also to run some of
the our code we are using our PI - so is
that creating any kind of overhead in
our
and we can just replace that with
something more optimized so for the very
first yeah we compared the timing for
all the different models that we are
running so the three bars that you can
see in the center reflects the our Auto
remote artery running on three different
transformations and we can see our auto
Reema is taking comparatively very high
time compared to other strategies so we
went ahead and looked closely at the
stats so just forget about Auto remove
for a minute and look at T Batson profit
so we can see the mean forecasting time
for T bats all the timings are in
seconds is just five seconds for profit
the mean is around just three seconds
and the max for T bats is 31 and profit
is just five seconds but now if we look
at Auto rima the mean is thirty three
seconds which is pretty high compared to
other two model and also if you look at
mean and then look at the 75th
percentile which is twenty four second
whereas mean is thirty three seconds
which signifies there's something going
wrong or there are some accounts which
are taking really a huge amount of time
to process and even if you look at the
max one of the account was taking
sixteen hundred seconds which is a
little lesser than half an hour so then
we looked at the distribution of the
data under second standard deviation and
we see just for the Autorama if you look
at the mean became half of what we had
for all the samples it is 19 seconds now
and the max is just to 32 seconds
looking at this with we came to a
position where we thought we'll be
implying a time threshold of 5 minutes
which is 300 seconds and we will just
timeout anything which is taking more
than 5 minutes and before we would have
went ahead doing that we thought of
analyzing how much forecasting strength
will we be losing if we do that so out
of all the thousand accounts
there were 26 accounts or 26 unique time
series which would have timed out in
case of auto Rhema but out of those 26
there are only 14 unique time series or
accounts which have our Auto Rhema as
the winning strategy and as we can see
this graph reflects on how many times
out of those 26 with strategies meaning
how much so our Auto Rhema with no
transformation is winning the most with
seven count so then the idea was to look
at the difference distribution which by
which I mean let's suppose for account
our Auto Rhema or profit is the winning
strategy compared that to what is the
next to winning strategy what is the
difference between them so we plotted
that on the left hand side as you can
see and compare that to the MFE or Jesus
keeping evaluation metric as MFE here so
we compared the different distribution
for the cases where our our Auto rima
was exceeding 300 seconds but was
winning for those accounts so if you
remember there were seven accounts for
our Auto rima with no transformation so
I'm just looking but just for the
visualization purpose here I'm just
showing only that case so as we can see
for more than half of the accounts which
is four accounts the difference is
pretty low though we have some of the
outliers so based on that we thought of
moving ahead and implementing 300
seconds or five minutes as our time
threshold so this helped us to gain 10%
of speed up with a maintainable
acceptable loss that we can have in
forecasting strength and then we are the
other problem that I mentioned we had
was our PI - that could have caused
overhead but before we could have went
ahead and analyze how much overhead our
PI - is causing we went to into a
problem when we were applying for the
time threshold our PI -
was not efficient to apply time
threshold it was not able to timeout at
a given time so so the only solution or
the solution that we came up with after
2 to get rid of our PI 2 was to build
individual scripts for all the our codes
and call them from a Python sub process
and then after that we figured one more
strategy out which was based in
structural time series it's kind of a
state space model we wanted to add that
and before adding that we again
experimented and how and see how it was
performing so yellow line reflects the
our base instructional time series and
it was performing considerably good
especially if we compare that to pi flux
which we saw was performing very poorly
for our use case so then we went ahead
and kept bsts as one of our strategy and
this is what became our concluding
pipeline and then second part is
optimizing for the scale and cost which
will be covered by jonathan stacks
thank you pronounce I'm going to talk
real briefly on a scale and cop scale
and cost optimization so now that we had
our forecast and what we were going to
run we needed a way to scale it up so
the first thing we looked at you can is
docker we've already been using this
pretty widely at c2fo there's a lot of
tools around deploying it and that we
had a deployment system already tailored
around this so from a show of hands how
many people have heard of or use docker
okay great I think for the scientific
Python community it could be a great fit
if you're using Conda it's really easy
to install your content environment into
a docker image the other benefit of this
is when you go to deploy across the
cluster you don't have to rebuild on
every single machine you can take that
immutable image and you can just
directly drop it on and then spin up as
many containers as you need and then one
final point you can run the same code in
production that you do on your local
machine so developers can develop and
there's no more throwing it over the
wall and saying well it worked on my
machine I don't know why it's not
working in production so this is the
basic architecture of our pipeline the
piece that we were breaking out and
optimizing was this piece right here
we're using celery just bend up a bunch
of doctor workers on ECS we're pulling
data out of redshift into a temporary
database and then all these workers are
consuming it doing the forecast and then
we're writing results up to s3 and then
those are going like that's Apache park'
and like we mentioned earlier we're
running docker on the sea for 8x large
instances and our main pipeline is in
Luigi so this is a better look at the
concurrency implementation so initially
we prime our database with data that we
plot of redshift it's not really
efficient to keep hitting it with lots
of workers where you're running lots of
forecasts so we do that initial load
once and then in ECS we spin up a
thousand workers right now they're all
processing data
we're using celery so we love the
messages on to the queue each worker
picks up a message that say I'm supposed
to process this account go to the
database gets the data starts turning it
and then writes the forecast at the s3
and then we're using reddit as a
back-end for celery so it's writing all
the task info and state there so we can
monitor them what's slower if anyone's
ever heard of that or flower I think
some people pronounce it so this is the
the basic implementation that we have
some stats that we have we're running
this across 28 instances since each one
is 36 cores that gives us a thousand and
eight cores when we run a thousand
workers we do about 2.6 million
forecasts and around 5.5 hours the 0.5
hours is mainly for cluster of spin up
time the whole pipeline runs in about 5
hours though one thing that I really
wanted to drive home here was if you
have the opportunity use spot instances
it requires a little bit more
configuration on your part
in the fact that you don't know when
that instances and go away so you need
to make sure that you're writing robust
infrastructure in code but the cost is
quite a reduction so the thing is - is
that you can lose them at any time
because it's based on a bidding model so
if a lot of people want to run spot
instances the price goes up so you have
to be aware of that but the cost per run
is about I think 40 percent so if you
can and you can write your architecture
around that I would say use spot
instances so so in conclusion
implementing all of this resulted in a
reduction of forecast and hair as you
can see this is on log scale but we've
shifted down the percent difference so
for now they're going to come back up
look Oh so yeah some of the future
improvements that we are thinking of is
running the experiment on scheduled
basis so that if any of the libraries
gets upgrades we can look for that
because one of the significant changes
that we figured out was in the case of
FB prophet they upgraded their library
and there was a significant change in
the results and then add some of the
regression models or the XG boosts that
I was talking so we are working on that
to extract the feature from time series
and add some of the regression models
and then investigate if we can if we can
move from Amazon to Google and if that
performs better we were also looking at
AWS batch there that would really help
decouple us from our data science team
and allow them to kind of self-service
their own jobs in addition AWS batch
also will spin up and down workloads
resulting in cost savings as well so
that was an exciting new product that we
want to look into so these are some of
the references that you can look for if
you want to know some of the more
details about the forecasting
pre-processing or even to know more
about c2fo so any questions
[Applause]
so parquet is something that should
repeat the question okay so the question
was why are we using power K so parquet
is actually something that we are
thinking of using down the line so that
rather than extracting all the data into
a temporary sequel for which we or
database or which we pay if we can get
all of the data in a flatten file and
we'll be more accessible any other
questions
I've got one okay so I'm curious I you
talked about sort of you know clearly
there was like this this part at the
beginning where you're like you know
kind of splashing around like trying
this out and then like you know at the
end you have this like clean like we've
got doctor we've got you know everything
running we can deploy it on ec2 like a
common thing that I see people spend a
lot of time beating your head against is
sort of like what are the smooth paths
or the things that work particularly
well or poorly from like you have some
people basically just wanting to write a
little bit of Python or r2 like DevOps
has something in their hands and there's
a smooth path to deploying that like you
know are there any other thoughts or you
know lessons learned that you might want
to offer from that part of the story
I'll take the first part the from our
talk it kind of seemed like a handoff in
the middle but we were definitely
involved early on we were working
through the same instance types and
running forecasts all the time early on
to even run our forecast in an automated
way and allow pro nobs do these
different experiments we actually
automated that so he could go in and he
would push up a branch of code that you
know maybe tweak something and then he
could go through and our automated
deployments if he could just hit deploy
and then the results were posted up an
s3 could pull them down analyze them
from any number of instances so that was
kind of something that we worked on
continuously and I would say it
definitely of the proves anyone to
involve DevOps or even like
infrastructure Ops teams earlier than
later
because they can work with you and they
can know what's going on I think that
that helps okay
currently primate
phone call mid question checklist for
the time after you ran all of your
experiments leave looking so bad for
like minute ago but what what does that
look like in practice like to get
something that you need to forecast you
pick one of them yeah so the question is
like if you're running different
strategies how you're picking up the
models right no so the thing is what we
figured out why we are using different
strategies because there are some
properties different amongst all the
different strategies and and all of the
time series data that we have doesn't
reflect the same characteristics so in
some cases we have a lot of trunk up
like days where we don't see any
transactions so there are some of models
that picks up that thing very well
whereas there are some models which
picks up the heavy data very well where
we have the transactions throughout our
time span so there are different time of
times of time see a time series that we
are dealing with and just because of
that there are different characteristics
each strategy have and they pick on that
so if we run them all and then we choose
the best one at the end yeah yeah that's
why we're running so many portal yeah so
as I mentioned so different evaluation
metrics that we are using so finally we
came right now we are working on having
a meta metric and we have combined MFE
and rmse together so combined some so
any strategy which has lower combined
some wins for a particular unique time
series or in account
so understanding why evaluation so
initially the idea was to use different
evaluation metrics if they are in
consensus and keep all of them and try
to build upon meta metrics which we can
use to compare different strategies and
pick up the best model using that I
think we really thank our speakers again
[Applause]